I had mental health issues and now I've
devoted my life so that was my
springboard why do I think it's
important one in four people do I need
to say anymore there's more mental
health problems than almost any other
illness and what's mental health mental
is physical do you know this is this is
an organ like everything else and when
it goes down you get no sympathy cards
but you know if we dealt with this one
forget calling it mental health let's
call it the brain a little more funding
then most diseases come from the mother
ship going down more and more people are
talking about mental health we've had
Prince William and Prince Harry
yeah beds together charity talking about
mental health but you say still people
don't have sympathy for people with
mental illness I think it's changing
there's no question and last time we
spoke there was gonna be parity between
physical disability and mental where is
that you know you well that's a good
question good luck getting it on the you
know get seeing a doctor and good luck
at work saying that you have a mental
illness well that's one of the problems
I mean since they promised parity there
are fewer mental health beds there are
fewer mental health you and I know that
and I mean so you believe not enough is
being done by because I answered your
own question they didn't do anything you
know the next day a hurricane came and
everybody's eyes went off the button but
this is a worse threat I don't want to
be a downer but this is the worst
tragedy than almost anything else you
know I don't want how many suicides with
young men cutting everything comes from
this is who you are
so government promises don't really mean
much and you think it should be treated
much more seriously you everybody does
everybody does it's the new epidemic but
they promised this extra money well tell
me where is it it's still it seems to me
a my my daughter got very ill we made a
documentary about it for channel 4 she
had a mental illness that manifested
itself as eating disorder we struggled
for facilities and resources which is
why we did documentary but where where
are the promises that the government
have made these are pages of more
resources it's a still a Cinderella
service it seems to me well let's say if
it's one in
and somebody's in the government if it's
not them problem is then it'll be a
relative it'll be a friend everything is
close to home so if we don't get more
resources for mental health what do you
fear could happen what do you think is
happening there's more crime now there's
more incidents of male suicide under 40
what do you think is going to happen you
know it's it's only gonna what we wish
it away this is a you know the enemy is
here in the absence of real resources
from government you now putting yourself
out there in you know organizing these
what are they called fragile cafes tell
us a little bit about that well the
point of that the point of it is is that
again where I'm trying to part of what
we're missing is community so we're all
kind of isolated tweeting for health you
know sending a photo of what we had for
lunch
we're very isolated and loneliness has
its own repercussions so I've started
frazzle cafes because it was my dream
always to if I had a group of people
that I could talk to it I could trust
I brought its half the Cure so this is
our first day where we're working in
partnership with Sky where they'll be
opening a frazzle cafe it's totally
confidential and I've been to a lot of
these we have them up and down the
country and you you could feel if this
is in Mountain Spence's now here at Sky
yeah they shot their cafe freedom free
coffee and cookies which they'll be
doing at sky and they have a chance now
to meet a support system without feeling
that they want to tell their family or
whatever and if you have somebody who
has mental illness they always say to me
what should I do
we'll come to the freslin cafe because
now you've got backup I want to ask you
about social media and the impact of
social media how much do you think this
contributes to you know mental illness
well here's my problem okay you see it
we're doing it now what stalking gonna
do you know what you think it's gonna go
away you know Moore's law it's
accelerating beyond your wildest dreams
don't worry about where it's going all
this what's that client I know where
it's going you know I my next book is
about where it's going
um we're gonna be Sci Burke's in a
second you know probably parts of you
maybe of cap teeth that's where it's
going so I've written a book how to be
human we really have to find where it is
and hold on for dear life before you get
any more you know
upgrades you know I I've had some of my
teeth kept but I'm pretty sure I'm still
me too but we really have to concentrate
on this thing called compassion and if a
parent is is neurotic about his kid the
kid on the you know on the digital thing
that he has to calm his brain down
otherwise the kid picks up your fear and
shouting isn't going to help but if you
can show your kid a really good time off
that thing
watch this face shouting is not only
going to make him hostile all right so
calm down yeah and show your kids be
funny yeah okay and take them somewhere
and just wean him off but never say you
can only stay on and hopefully someday
this is what I'm hoping they'll have
something like a you know the physical
Fitbit they'll have a mental Fitbit so
you can read your own hormone you know
cortisol levels it says you're hitting
your peak put the Machine down calm down
then you can come back we really need to
understand what's our mental state
otherwise we're just competing with the
next guy to get faster and slicker all
right Ruby Wax thank you the world's
problems you have sold everything
everything